should accept yourself just the way you
are what does that say about who I
should become is that just now off the
table because I'm already good enough in
every way so am I done or something get
the hell up get your act together adopt
some responsibility put your life
together develop a vision unfold all
those manifold possibilities that lurk
within be a force for good in the world
and that'll be the adventure of your
life
[Music]
the world's falling birth rate isn't on
the list of major threats to Life as we
know it but it soon will be
taxes are destined to soar pension
systems will become unsustainable while
our Health Care Systems won't be able to
cope with the ratio of all people to
take care of compared to the shrinking
number of taxpayers businesses will
struggle to find workers to hire school
closures will accelerate while social
care will continually be sliced and they
say it's an economic Time Bomb I'm
worried about the birth rate most people
think we we have like too many people on
the planet but actually this is an
outdated view I think that the biggest
problem the world will face in 20 years
is population collapse
I want to emphasize this the biggest
issue in 20 years will be population
collapse
[Music]
hello everyone I'm here today talking to
Mr Stephen J Shaw Stephen is a British
national who has studied and lived on
three continents he trained as a
commuter engineer and then as a data
scientist
before starting his first film Project
birth Gap at age 49.
he maintains the position of president
of the data analytics company he
co-founded automatrix analytics LLC
Stephen holds an MBA graduate business
degree from isg in Paris France and is
continuing his studies at the Harvard
Extension School looking very much
forward today to delving into the issue
of declining
birth rates and population collapse
something that's not particularly on
everyone's radar and the issue of
um
the invisible epidemic of unplanned
childlessness
why are people having so few children
the more I read about falling birth
rates
everything was negative
you enter a downward spiral as you have
fewer and fewer children you have fewer
and fewer future mothers which in turn
goes on and on and on
and no Society in history has been known
to come out of that spiral
so I'm talking today with Stephen J Shaw
who's produced a documentary birth Gap
that was originally released in its
first version in 2021 and later version
in 2022 and he's been spending an awful
lot of time delving into this particular
problem and so we're going to walk
through what he's learned uh good to see
you thank you for inviting me hey thanks
for agreeing to talk so
let's start with your background we
could walk through what you what you've
been up to biographically first of all
to situate it and then you can expand on
that to the degree that you're willing
and able so
um historically for the last 20 years
I've been involved in data analytics
what we now call data science I'm a
parts Devastation part coder I've worked
with some grid academics some phds that
we have on staff and coming up with
academic models forecasting models for
Industries mainly in the automotive
sector we try and do short-term
forecasting what might people purchase
what should car companies Bill what
should they Market what should they give
for incentives down to a very minute
level this is a private Venture it is
and and so it's a corporation that
offers these Services yeah it's a small
Niche Corporation that's been offering
services to the world's largest
corporations for 20 years and how did
you get involved in that it was a
startup in London 20 years ago I
personally moved to the U.S to we got a
contract with Nissan North America took
me to La and following that yeah I spent
like 15 years
following the company Hands-On
until around 2015
uh bizarrely and I should explain I'm a
lifelong learner I'd gone I got accepted
into Harvard Extension school to do
become a degree candidate to keep my
data science skills up to date
and I was presented with some data that
I just couldn't believe on falling birth
rates so someone who is involved in
forecasting will be a short-term
forecasting
realizing that we've got this
fundamental problem
with birth rates that's ultimately going
to affect well not just the number of
potential car buyers I mean that's the
smallest problem in this overall but
that was you know something I felt
almost ashamed of why do I know this and
then you expand that to what is this
going to mean for the planet and as a
father of three all my three children
were just about still teenagers then
I felt sense of failure that I hadn't
been preparing my children for the world
they were about to enter into you know
we all I think are LED into the belief
that sure that the world's population is
growing perhaps exponentially still
that's what I would have said at that
time based on what I was learning and I
had no idea that the actual dynamics of
everything from how work is going to be
like to how Society is going to be like
to how pension systems are going to be
like
is fundamentally fundamentally flawed
and
at that moment I realized something's
wrong because you know what the same
trend
was showing up for Germany and Italy and
Japan South Korea yeah well South Korea
was just a little bit later just a
little bit later which is interesting
but something triggered the early 1970s
in Japan Germany Italy and you can add
Spain Portugal Switzerland Austria
because
apparel a series of parallel Trends and
yet
while I was reading from experts was
that these are localized problems but
Japan is work-life balance that in
Germany it's something called raven
mother which is the idea that parts of
Germany even today for a woman to have a
child and go straight back to work is
really something that culturally
shouldn't be done so that might cause
some peoples to delay Parenthood in
Spain and Italy it was down to high
unemployment among among the youth other
areas it was gender balance Etc so all
these localized reasons were being
proposed
for me as a data scientist you can see
clearly of
if I can give you an analogy it's one of
your own I I you were talking to Lex
Friedman you talked about the dragon I
think in terms of the environment
context that someone finds a dragon and
they scream there's a dragon and I love
the analogy and I since saw that you use
dragons quite a lot so I thought I might
too
and it's like you found this little
dragon in Japan and the same kind of
dragon in Germany Italy at the same
moment in time and they're starting to
get bigger and that's all so they're
lizards to begin with right I mean
they're tiny they're the size of a
kitten I think is an analogy I saw and
they're getting bigger and then suddenly
they're appearing in other neighboring
countries and it's growing growing
growing from there so the idea that
these are localized issues to me just
did not make sense so why do you think
you were struck to begin with by the
fact that birth rates were plateauing or
declining I mean because the typical
response to that would be either so what
there's too many people on the planet
anyways or actually it's a net good so
now you said you you're in a private
company now I should let everybody
watching and listening know that
one of the markers for the
trustworthiness of a data analytic
company is that people will actually pay
for their information and so you know it
doesn't necessarily mean that a private
data analytic company is uh credible but
it does mean at least that they've been
able to demonstrate their credibility
enough so that they have paying
customers and that's not an easy thing
to manage and so you were doing
short-term forecasting that was
integrated into the capitalist economy
let's say yes to help people plan their
product development and so forth but you
came across this data at a much broader
level indicating uh plateauing birth
rate our our population growth why did
that disturb you why did you think that
was a problem
because birth rates less than
replacement level spiraled onwards they
never stalled
if you have fewer children that are
required to replace the parents
generation once that generation grows up
they will if unless birth rates change
which they don't historically they stay
low once they're low you're going to
have fewer people again so you see it as
a as a positive feedback loop it is and
when you you then look up well what do
you you want to find examples of
societies coming from a low birth rates
going back to replacement level and you
realize there are no examples in fact
there's no known his historical examples
anywhere and some people do we have
enough of a historical track to consider
that a concern
in modern times if you look at the
number of countries who've Fallen to
birth rates of 1.7 1.6 1.5 when you have
no single example of a country going
back to a replacement level we should be
concerned in fact we should be very
concerned right I know places like
Quebec for example in Canada with very
very low birth rate have tried to
Institute government policies that for
example make daycare in principle more
accessible to to young women and in
young families although that's had
pretty much zero impact on the outcome I
know that Hungary has put forward a
series of policy Transformations on the
Family Support front and my my uh belief
is from what I've read is that they've
at least stopped the birth rate decrease
and
increased it slightly so that's the only
I mean Quebec didn't work at all Hungary
it looks like there's some minor they're
still way below replacement so it hasn't
rectified the problem in any in any
sense
here's the deal the government keeps
raising rates because it's the only tool
they have to keep inflation under
control and it's not working you can't
spend your way out of inflation you've
seen the impact on the stock market and
you've seen the impact on your savings
hedge inflation by owning gold whether
physical gold and silver in your safe or
through an IRA in Precious Metals where
you can hold real gold and silver in
attack sheltered retirement account buy
gold and get a free safe to store it in
that's right unqualifying purchases from
Birch gold group now through March 31st
they'll ship a free safe directly to
your door just text Jordan to 989898 to
get your free info kit on gold and to
claim eligibility for your free safe
then talk to one of their precious
metals Specialists that's Jordan to
989898 today
what's fascinating about Hungary
um
because what I wanted to do was look at
something much deeper than the typical
birth rate numbers of that we see today
I'm trying to change that
if you look deeper you can find data
that if you merge together which I don't
believe anyone had ever done before that
gives you two measures one is of
societal childlessness
and the other is family structure
so
um the traditional way to measure is
childlessness is to wait to women are 45
usually and have some surveys maybe a
census so you're waiting to the to the
end of the fertility window and Counting
them then what I wanted to see was what
a societal challenge is today if there's
a reduction in the number of women
starting their families compared to what
you would expect we should be able to
track that now so looking at Hungary
which I've just been doing recently was
fascinating I mean they're giving huge
incentives for people to have three and
four children
but the family structure and hunger is
not changing at all at all what is
changing which may or may not be linked
it's associative in some way
um but causal we don't know is that is a
childlessness rate and hungry does seem
to be going down more people look like
they're starting their families and what
happens then is when people Circle
families they go on because family
structure is locked in globally that's
another Finding and so Andrew what do
you what do you mean so we'll go in two
directions what do you mean what what
are you speaking about when you're
talking when you're expressing your
concerns about family structure well
family structure basically is the
percentage of women we say women because
we've got so much data in women but
really we should think of men and women
the proportion of
women couples who have one child or two
or three or four or five or more if you
take data for Japan
and you look at
1973 right before the Fallen birth rates
the percentages of women having one two
three four are identical today as they
were then six percent of women in 1973
were having four or more children today
it's exact same number six percent
so the our Focus has been completely uh
if you would be not a fog looking at
overall birth rates
what you find is in Japan in 1974
interesting year an explosion in
childlessness which went from three
percent to six percent to 15 to 21 to 30
plus percent in a space for like four
years
Sam in Italy the same in Germany four
years in four years it's a shock it was
a what I call a baby shock
and then if you look at Korea South
Korea which you mentioned earlier if we
take South Korea mid 90s right in the
midst of a currency shock you see
Charles Ritz were already maybe 15 there
suddenly it goes up to I believe 30
percent announce or 40 and this is
childless at what age well when I uh
estimate childlessness I'm taking the
for the given population of women the
number of births you'd expect to have at
any age and say how many first-time
mothers were there
and when you kind of the number of
first-time mothers of any age group and
look at the overall population structure
you can see well wait a minute there's a
gap opening up here compared to the
number you would expect so this is like
age agnostic in a sense okay and as a
measure the you know people say well
some of those women might you know there
might be a boom in future people might
be just delaying but that doesn't happen
there's no example of those booms ever
happening
so it seems to be we've got this cycle
going on uh that people are pulled quite
quickly into this
um What I Call On World unplanned
childlessness if I can I've had to coin
quite a few phrases
um I'll explain I should explain what
what it might mean by unplanned
childlessness
you um look at surveys
uh look at research the vast majority of
people want children it's an aid
and some don't that's clear what
percentage do approximately I'm
estimating around five percent don't
they've been Gallup polls in the US Don
is that different between men and women
um I I don't have that data but okay so
five percent you figure are are out of
the game yes by voluntary Choice yes
right and and what percentage are are
childless well right now we're looking
at 30 to 40 percent the most developed
Nations so the vast majority 80 percent
said its estimated in studies and I
think this that's that involuntarily
involuntary childlessness and I've been
thinking about that lately we have this
notion for men of involuntary celibacy
in cells we don't have a term that's as
at hand for involuntary childlessness
among women and it hasn't been
recognized as a like what would you call
it a universal uh social problem but you
just said five percent of women don't
want children but 30 percent don't don't
have them and so there's a huge gap
there between desire and reality
I think frankly I believe it's the
biggest societal problem that we have
and it's hiding because we haven't
recognized it and if you find people as
I did making a documentary
um people who are struggling
the 30s late 30s
women particularly but men too who have
given up in their 40s and they're
opening their heart to you with a level
of what they call grief yeah
and in English language grief is used
for one particular context it's not
necessarily used normally for something
you never had yeah I think in other
languages there there are terms that
that Encompass that but it's the same
emotion and I've been pulled into
conversations where I have frankly been
brought myself to the depths of
understanding the suffering from these
people who
thought they were going through life
getting the education probably yeah
starting the career path probably
thinking that well you know what I'm not
30 yet
I've got time to meet a partner yeah and
then getting to the point of often there
is no partner yes or that biology gets
in the way yeah well it turns out that
life is shorter than people think you
know I've I've had clinical clients who
have followed that path and and some of
them were women who had initially
decided that they didn't want to have
children and then changed their minds
quite dramatically in their late 20s
which is very common pattern and then
couldn't have children and it was just
absolutely disastrous for them they were
often on the you know artificial
fertility route for 10 years with
multiple miscarriages and failures on
that front and it's a bloody dismal
outcome did you want uh children
sing sing
[Music]
my eyes
only
um
I think if you caught me at the right
day in my 20s when I was very in love or
excited about a partner I would say yes
but if you were to pry into that I might
say oh no that seems crazy to have a kid
in my 20s
too late
okay so you're making a case here you're
making a psychological case in some
sense at the moment in that this is
um a phenomenon worth attending to
because the vast majority of people who
end up childless which is a a more
serious immediate problem for women
because of the biological restrictions
on their reproductive capacity the
reason that's a problem is because so
many women
end up in that situation despite wanting
children so that's a real psychological
problem but you could take a
sociological stance and say well as
we've been uh as has been insisted upon
for 60 years there's too many people on
the planet and it's just not a bad thing
at all if we stop reproducing in this
manner and if the price we have to pay
for reduction in the number of excess
mods to feed is that there are some
unhappy women so be it what do you think
about this at a sociological or
political or economic level
first of all I think that's a terribly
sad thing to contemplate that we have to
and somehow
somehow enforce
perhaps lifelong grief and sadness on a
subset of society who were mostly
unlucky enough not to have the children
they wanted to have for the sake of the
planet when there are other hypothetical
hypothetical right yeah at some future
time at some future time and to me the
first thing my reaction strong reaction
isn't there another way if that's right
and then you look at data as a reported
in nature last year on the overall
footprint by each group
quite a number of scientists put their
name to it and it says very clearly that
eight percent of our footprint occurs
when we're aged under 30.
then it rises quite significantly
between 30 and around 65 I believe and
that falls off sharply
well that means that if the world's
births were to magically well it
wouldn't be magic dropped by say half I
love taking extreme situations so let's
imagine that from Tomorrow only half the
birth happened for some crazy reason
that eight percent of total emissions or
footprint would go down to four percent
in 30 years time this is going to have
almost no impact
for decades at a time when I think we
have to find other Solutions as much as
they're needed to solve problems that
are out there so the idea that we're
going to inflict this pain deep personal
suffering pain in people and perhaps be
pleased about it as I know some people
are
um I I think it's terrible terribly sad
I I think it might be that to come back
I would like to clarify that for those
people who don't have a desire you know
I will I consider myself a pan-natalist
you don't want to have children I would
be your biggest supporters to say that's
fine
and I think there might be a
misunderstanding in society for some
people who perhaps don't share that
desire who perhaps can't quite
understand how fundamental this desire
is yeah well most people who are in that
boat are being willfully blind
in my experience and so the idea that
there are reasons to not want to have
children one reason is an overwhelming
self-centered narcissism that's not the
only reason but it's definitely one
reason and people talk about you know
the interference with their personal
freedom and their desire to pursue their
career and in that I read something like
the absolute inability to ever sacrifice
your own narrow self-interest and I do
mean narrow to the to the what would you
say concerns and needs of other people
and so
you know what's interesting to me that
it's five percent
that don't want children and that the
the rate of that kind of self-centered
narcissism is about four to five percent
too now I am not saying that everyone
who who decides not to have children
falls into that category but I am saying
that a fair number of people who don't
want children fall into that category I
mean if you think about it biologically
every single one of your maternal
ancestors for three and a half billion
years reproduce successfully it might be
that you're the exception to that rule
but you know if you are you should think
long and hard about why you also might
want to think long and hard about why
given that it's likely to have a pretty
damn detrimental effect on your life you
know it's all fine to be fancy free and
Footloose when you're 30 and 35 but it's
a lot less amusing when you're 50 and it
might be downright Dreadful by the time
you're let's say 65. so all right so on
the on the population front now we
talked a little bit about the
psychological catastrophe of involuntary
childlessness I'm curious too about the
social and economic uh consequences so
as you get a demographic bulge more and
more older people and fewer and fewer
younger people obviously you have fewer
people to take care of the older people
but I also have never really read
anything pertaining to models of like
real estate value collapse because it
doesn't take very long if there are more
houses than there are people for the
value of real estate to fall to well to
what to nothing I mean that's what
happened in Detroit it basically fell to
nothing I mean Detroit is recovered to
some degree but we don't know at all
what the world would look like if
real estate values fell to virtually
nothing especially because that's where
most people put their retirement value
so what do you see what do you foresee
happening on the
political and economic front
given the
shift towards the elderly
demographically we're going to see it in
China first right clearly
clearly um well Japan too Japan one of
the reasons I moved to live in Japan is
to be close to I wanted to feel this
problem yeah I wanted to be able to see
it and almost touch it and you can there
but you mentioned Detroit
um I spent many many years living in the
suburbs of Detroit
and right around the time I was looking
to start this project uh you know that I
was able to drive around the streets of
Detroit and see Street after Street of
the street of tens and tens of thousands
of thick you know the decaying houses
yeah yeah I remember one day driving
along and there was a house and these
were nice houses right back in the day
right still spacious
and there was a young family having a
picnic I'd say one of these houses
and it was the perfect setting you might
say in every context except every other
house in history looked like they were
completely vacant the dilapidated
um around that time
listening to local Detroit News every
night it was crying it was street lights
that weren't functioning yeah it was
lack of safety it was like a functioning
of basic utilities it was infrastructure
and bridges that the City couldn't
afford and of course in 2013 it went
bankrupt so I had this backdrop to
knowing what was happening to to Detroit
the city and you write about property
value around that time you could buy a
significant property in Detroit for ten
thousand dollars yeah you probably
couldn't go there to ever see it because
it wasn't safe at that time right right
and you were right Detroit has come back
so in some ways it is a time of a
demolished huge tracks of houses but how
do you do that when half the houses are
still occupied you go through this
period of time unless you're going to
say to people everybody move three
streets over now and you do that every
few years
not easily go into neighborhoods and
start moving things back to to nature
which is what Detroit's doing you you
can individual houses but you know you
still have these scars of the empty
spaces that were there and I showed some
of this in the documentary so the idea I
mean people I I was on a podcast Chris
Williamson's recently yeah I just it was
the first time I got you know a sense of
the comments that people make and many
people were sharing these deep personal
stories about their life to do with
unplanned chalices yeah
um others were sharing concerns about
whether they ever become grandparents
and right so but a lot of people were
saying
well this is just about economics you
know who cares this is just about big
Corporation suffering who cares
I think people need to understand this
is going to impact everybody everybody's
life if you're living in an area where
there's literally decay dilapidation all
around you and the taxes that you're
paying to your city or your municipality
aren't covering the basic infrastructure
no one's going to escape from this I
think people don't understand that so in
my case
um
understanding life in Detroit and again
I really love this city it's great you
know I love the people
um I I love the way it is starting to
come back
but that experience I think really spoke
to me that we really need to think about
what this means now you talk about the
social economic I mean the economics you
know go beyond the city and the property
values it's the it's a Pension funds
it's a social welfare funds that you
know people think I think I did too at
the time that you know the retirement
the cost to maintain each of us in a
retirement is basically what the
government or someone's been saving for
when we get to that age yeah it's not
what we're paying right that's a bargain
with the future that's a bargain yeah
you're covering the people who are
retired now what the government has put
away for us is debt debt yeah yeah
there's no savings and then there's a
promise right and then that's a problem
because yes that's for sure if you have
a shrinking number of taxpayers that's
not shrinking so the repayment on the
debt actually becomes worse and worse
and worse yeah well and hypothetically
you can remediate that with immigration
but then that opens up another can of
worms which is no one really knows what
the maximal rate of incorporation a
society can manage without imploding
right I mean obviously Canada the US U.S
in particular is an immigrant society
and that's worked out extremely well for
the immigrants and for this Society but
the idea that there's no upper limit to
our capacity to digest and integrate
let's say is absolutely Preposterous so
and and we don't know but the notion
that we can replenish at the rate that
we're losing on the birth rate front
strikes me as it's at least a debatable
claim
we'll be right back first we wanted to
give you a sneak peek at Jordan's new
series Exodus
so the Hebrews created history as we
know it
you don't get away with anything and so
you might think you can bend the fabric
of reality and that you can treat people
instrumentally and that you can bow to
the Tyrant and violate your conscience
without cost you will pay the piper it's
going to call you out of that slavery
into Freedom even if that pulls you into
the desert
and we're going to see that there's
something else going on here that is far
more Cosmic and deeper than what you can
imagine the highest
[Music]
Spirit to which we're beholden is
presented precisely as that spirit that
allies itself with the cause of Freedom
against tyranny
I want villains to get punished but do
you want the villains to learn before
they have to pay the ultimate price
that's such a Christian question
immigration is a subject that uh you
know I think um we we actually only look
at one side of it and I certainly did
until I went to Nepal and I went and I
sat down with a professor of the head of
the department population Professor
Patak in one of the largest universities
in Asia and I wanted to talk about
falling birth rates in the power which
we're just about replacement level at
that time
and all he wanted seem to want to talk
about was the Pains of migration on
Nepal the people the communities they're
left behind
I'd never for one second had thought
about this dark side of you know
immigration oh you've had your brain
drain for example Community Tree yeah
you're actually taking you're leaving
the old parents there and you're sending
you know remittances back and that seat
is positive but those parents aren't
really looking for remittances they're
looking for people community their
children to be there
to into their older age
and you know we went to film some of
these older people and you know the
looks on their forlorn looks in their
face no one thinks about that and then
you have another situation which is
often it's men who are the immigrants at
least first yeah and well okay so maybe
that seems
to some a good way for it to start but
there's another Dark Side to that is the
the woman behind are either not married
yet or they are married and there are
men have gone off elsewhere and they're
not having children right
or their husbands coming back for three
weeks a year
and you've got three weeks a year to try
and get pregnant and of course most are
not so you actually are propelling
countries into low birth rates the same
factor that the rest of us are going
through right now
so the immigration debate and I'm an
immigrant myself you know I've been an
immigrant to to the U.S to Japan now
um so I'm I'm absolutely not against
immigration at all as you say it's done
great service to U.S Canada and many
other countries too
um but the idea that yeah but that
doesn't mean it's a solution
right right right now you talked about
Japan let's talk about Japan a little
bit you how long did you live in Japan I
still do so I've been there for five
years and and you said you you can well
so what do you experience there in
relationship to your concerns about
population decline let me tell you about
the community in um
rural Tokyo so this is what the world's
biggest city based on some measures you
go to the Northwestern part of Tokyo and
there's an area called takashimadayara
that's featured in the documentary
1973 the 10 000 homes in this apartment
were filled with young families
and there's all footies where you see
you know just children everywhere I went
back with someone who was a child in
those days
and you know you can hear the voices of
the past and today it's a ghost town but
it's not unoccupied 98 of the apartments
are still occupied but they're old
people and they're mostly old women
right living alone yes and they're old
women because men die early men die
early right so this is another that's
exactly right so one of the things that
you see as
young people disappear and as the
population ages is that the landscape is
made up of isolated old women
who no one cares about right a dismal
Destiny for all concerned
you know I I'd love people frankly to
watch the documentary to really sense
this because you know there's one scene
there and it's it is harrowing but uh uh
to put in simple terms there's an 80
year old woman who has no family
who's contemplating suicide
because she's nothing to live for no one
to live for and no one to communicate no
she should move to Canada we have a nice
medically assisted death program here
that's I think accounting for something
like three to five percent fall deaths
now so you know yeah there's a solution
for everyone to contemplate yeah well I
just worry in fact it was a Japanese
Professor who came out the other day a
week ago suggesting that it would be uh
morally appropriate for the older people
in Japan to consider suicide as a root
out because they're a burden to the but
they're a burden to society
and now he's backtracking saying he
didn't really mean that but but it's
dangerous once you start to put that out
there because there are people you know
I remember a conversation with a young
woman in Japan and uh or talking about
her future and I did that with a lot of
people over 230 people I interviewed in
24 countries and she mentioned that her
grandmother was living with her family
but she mentioned the burden of her
grandmother to the family
and she came out with the point that I
guess many might be thinking when you're
that age why is she still here
and when you hear that you know and then
you meet
people who are that age who I think of
still so much to give to society I mean
they're just excluded from it they're
not well it's hard if they're not
integrated in anything well sometimes
it's hard if they are integrated into a
family but it's definitely harder if
they're not it's also the case that a
lot of people who contemplate suicide
do that not so much because they're
specifically suffering although that can
certainly be a contributing factor but
because they do believe that they are
fundamentally best construed as a burden
and that the world including the people
around them would be better off if they
disappeared
so that's a that's a very sad uh what
would you say realm to inhabit in your
misery and isolation so can can we can
we walk through the structure of the
documentary yes of course yeah so it's
just so everyone listening is reminded
it's called the name of the documentary
is birth Gap and so let's walk through
the structure of it
the um first of all the title birth Gap
I could just explained why is it called
birth Gap what is a birth Gap
to me it's what I defined as the gap
between the number of old people to
support in society and births so it's
it's an indication of frankly a measure
that we're not taking account of today
what is that ratio
so to me
to be very honest with you you know
whether we hit 9 billion or maybe 10
um is it's trivial you know it's going
to happen it's going to be in that
ballpark whether we like it or not
that's going to happen yeah and
um what actually matters is the age
structure so birth Gap the title of the
movie that's where it comes from
um before I went on this journey chapter
one
is me literally going with an iPad
showing people data uh we started in
Italy Switzerland we went to Japan and
just started to talk to people about
what's happening in their own societies
so how did you move into the realm of
documentary filmmaking
well
I have to thank my my second son Adam
for that because my idea at this point I
mean I'm not a filmmaker uh certainly
wasn't then
my thought was this is a big problem I
can write a book about this I thought
just about I have the ability to write
to explain this
and what I wanted to do because there's
other books out there has come up with a
new way to help visualize this problem
and to use the book to kind of
communicate and I thought well Maps no
one's really come up with the structure
of a map
and in doing this I was explaining to my
son Adam and he um said that no one our
age his age reads books anymore we all
watch documentaries right right or
listen to them or listen to them yeah
and for me you know well that's not me
there's no way I could possibly do that
and then by chance a friend of a friend
who's a former videographer news anchor
for a Washington DC uh News Network
um but was going out in her own and long
story short we well okay let's see if we
can make this work and it brought her
along for two weeks to film the first
interviews thinking of nothing else this
is going to be an archive right for my
own research right right right
um save me note taking while I'm
listening to all of these people and as
we got into it the personal stories
opened up of people who you could see
them contemplating the future of their
lives like one Springs to mind a Young
Elementary School teacher in Switzerland
30 years old a young man and
when we walk through with him the future
of elementary schools in Switzerland
you could see the process in his mind
realizing we're not going to need
anywhere near the number of elementary
school teachers that we have now and
what that might mean for him
um so the documentary starts literally
with me asking people in countries why
is this happening and
um
frankly you know I was hoping
um you know in this entire project I was
expecting at some point to sit down and
do some form of regressive model you
know to find a correlation between
something that would link uh these small
dragons these uh you know uh
falling birth rates in Japan Germany and
elated because they were happening at
the same time and they were spreading
I never got to that point and I'm very
grateful I didn't because I probably
would have found something like you know
ice cream sales you know happened at the
same time some serious thing with it
it's very hard to to identify the well
it seems obvious that I mean one of the
causes the distal causes I would say
clearly is the promotion
of the birth control pill but even that
is a
somewhat shallow answer because there's
a very specific set of Social and
economic
realities Zeitgeist that even made the
invention and distribution and
acceptance of the birth control possible
Right you had to have the psychological
stage set for the acceptance of that
technology the demand for that
technology before it could be developed
or implemented and so
well so okay so you you started the
documentary you're in chapter one you're
starting to ask people what's going on
what are they telling you yeah well no
one had a clear answer and that you know
maybe that was overly simplistic but
what I was trying to do is find some
common thread but let me just if I can
talk about
contraceptives because there's a
wonderful culture example
the contraceptive pill was not legalized
in Japan until 1990.
hmm
and
it was only legalized because Viagra was
legalized and at that point women said
wait you've been blocking the
contraceptive pill and now you're
allowing Viagra and at that point was so
you had the precipitous decline in birth
rate from 73. you had an increase in
Mass abortions
so this was a societal issue with or
without so okay so that shows that it's
something deeper than this feel deeper
and also if you look at other countries
particularly UK at the time France to
the US where you also had access to the
contraceptive pill you were not seeing
falling birth rates
and a lot of people
um would say well it's obvious it was
industrialization it was something to do
with urbanization but the correlations
aren't there if you look at well why did
this only happen in those three
countries and the answer comes back to a
lot of people to see unfold in the
documentary but it's a sudden increase
in this unplanned involuntary
childlessness happened in Germany Italy
those countries at the same time that's
definitely the case that as women become
more educated they have fewer children
and that that's now
the precise causal pathway there isn't
obvious one simple
suggestion would be that
it is a matter of accidental delay I
mean by I've seen this in my daughter
you know my daughter although she had
terrible health problems and that
complicated your life a lot she had
initially thought that she might want to
go be a physician but that's like 12
years and she was also very oriented
towards having children and she's
managed to have one child despite her
health problems but
that desire to pursue an intense
educational pathway does exist in
Conflict certainly with an early start
to
to family development
if you presume that that doesn't matter
because you've got time you're not going
to find out that isn't true for
10 years in your own life and maybe the
culture won't find out that's true for
like 30 years you know I mean we still
tell y'all young women who are 19. I
made a comment
on that was clipped on an Instagram reel
by someone
about the fact that we always lie to
young women about what's going to be
important in their lives we tell them
it's going to be all career he said you
know I've worked in female dominated
Industries my whole life and what I've
observed is
among men and women alike that
it's a very rare person for whom career
is the most important thing in their
life even if they're men although it's
true for more men it's true for
virtually no women by the time they hit
30 and the amount of vitriol that
comment generated was unparalleled and
that's something because I've had plenty
of vitriol generated from things I said
but that was and it was all young women
you know talking about how some old
white guy like me had no right to tell
young women what to do with their bodies
which I most certainly was not but
but it is
you can see a simple pathway there right
it's like well we have this Avenue where
we can pursue our career in our
education and everything else we want
and then we'll be able to solve the
problem of having a family the problem
with that is
well it's hard enough to find a mate
when you're 23 24 by the time you're 30
it's even more difficult and by the time
you're 35 it's starting to become well
nigh impossible to find a mate and get
pregnant and have a family especially if
you're going to have more than one kid
and so
well so there's a there's a direct
conflict there uh between
The Avenues that are open to women and
they the need to to strike while the
Iron's heart on the reproductive front
nobody really knows how to reconcile
that I mean it's all Audi because women
will live about seven years longer than
men so it could be the case that the
societal Norm could be that women have
their children when they're quite young
and then go back to school in their 30s
that would actually work out in
principle that could work out quite
nicely but we don't have the Norms in
place to make that a possibility but we
have to start addressing exactly this
because if we don't you know uh to me I
mean there's so many ideas today about
reproductive technology that are oh yeah
overstated yes freeze your eggs yeah age
40. you know if you have a partner and
if you still have energy that you might
then yes and everything goes well yeah
if everything and you have the money
yeah and you add the emotional stamina
all of that so part of what I'm
um
hoping to do through the documentary in
my work after this is to just increase
awareness particularly to women but you
need a man as well so it's both that the
fertility window is much shorter and the
ability of children gets harder and
harder and it's not just about getting
pregnant it's about being able to
deliver you know and be able to see the
pregnancy through to which gets
exponentially harder very very quickly I
should mention I interviewed five
fertility doctors for the documentary
itself
um and you know each one of them wanted
to open up about the challenges because
normally they have to sell their
services right normally you have to tell
people think possibly here's what we've
done for other people here we think we
can do it for you yeah what they were
telling to me openly I'm frankly getting
quite emotional about it on a couple
occasions was it terrible because so
often it doesn't work out but one in
three couples by the age of 30 have
pronounced fertility problems defined as
inability to conceive within a year of
embarking on the Endeavor consciously
right so that's one in three and of
course it just gets worse and worse as
as age creeps up and 30 is not that old
and it does mean that women have a damn
tight window
it's it's 13 years let's say by the time
you're 17 by some standards you're
mature enough to consider reproduction
17 or 18 and on that on the extreme end
and and then well 35 is the other end of
that distribution and uh you're playing
with fire
by the time you're delaying especially
if you don't have a partner by the time
you're delaying till till 35. especially
if you want three children you know yeah
well right I'm thinking just one you
know and and it's also the case I think
if you're a reasonable Observer of human
nature you see that people have
three sources of fundamental
gratification in their lives one is
their the pursuit of their own interests
including career and job
one is their intimate relationship and
the other is their family and obviously
the intimate relationship and the family
are very integrally Associated and if
you miss out on one of those you may be
able to fill it by exceptional ability
in the remaining domains but for most
people not only is that highly unlikely
it's also highly undesirable so to come
because to take the point as well here
am I you know an older uh male talking
about things that are very sensitive to
women but there there are a lot of women
out there saying the exact same thing
and you know there was one this morning
I got got an email from Melanie notkin
who's written a book called other Hood
um who herself has no children and she
put it succinctly that in her words
women are going through the education
path the career path to try to
ultimately fall in love and have a
family yeah right it's all linked yeah
well I think it's the same for men I
think so no well half the reason half
it's more than that half the reason that
men strive for Career Success is to
impress women and attract them in fact
it's higher than that so but but maybe
that point is the heart of the problem
we have today because today if you look
at who's at college
and who's actually earning more right
now I read this morning women in in
cities in the US are earning more than
men I don't know if that's right or
wrong but you have this situation that's
right under 30. yeah so in U.S colleges
right now they're I believe it's 9.5
million women and Iran 6.57 million men
oh and the women start dropping out of
college by the way when the when they
when the when they start out remember
the man two to one
right because a lot of the reason people
go to college you know you've got to ask
yourself what's college for it's like
well let's get educated to go to
lectures to be accredited it's like no
probably not probably the reason people
go to college is to find a bait and
there's a selected pool there and you
have a decent chance of finding someone
you know of approximately your ability
and and uh forward-looking Vision let's
say and the reason people are willing to
Shell out between 150 and 250 000 for
four years is in no small part so they
can find a mate well if you demolish
that by well radically decreasing the
number of available men for example
you're just going to blow the whole
Enterprise out of the water which is
already what's happening and absolutely
um and this is perhaps my greatest
concern because I think if we make young
people more aware of fertility the
fertility window they might want to have
children earlier if we link that to in
some way enabling careers later in life
yeah which has to fundamentally happen
this to work we might still be left with
a situation where women who the term is
hypergenic where people women we want to
marry someone at least as educated at
least as successful taller than they are
yeah but if we're in a situation where
there's so few men getting the same
level of Education we might be left with
this imbalance oh yeah so that's already
happening clearly yeah it's very
difficult for women to overcome the
hypergamous uh Instinct because they're
trying to redress the imbalance in terms
of reproductive responsibility there's
no evidence at all you get a little bit
of flattening of hypergamy and extremely
egalitarian societies like Scandinavia
but it certainly doesn't disappear and
so that's that's built in at a very
fundamental biological level and I don't
think any casual tinkering on the
anthropological or sociological front is
going to shift that a bit so that's a
big problem it's a big problem it's also
the case too that if marriages where the
wife out earns or out statuses the
husband tend to be comparatively
unstable and violent so you know now you
can lay that at the feet of the man if
you're inclined to but it does but in
some sense it doesn't really matter
because that's the way it is and so the
women are unhappy and the men are
threatened and that's just not a good
rip that's not a good uh recipe for
marital stability so everyone loses in
this situation and so let's talk about
another country Thailand so you you
would think if you'd ask me how many
women are in college in Thailand I might
have said 15 I have no idea but no it's
55 percent
40 percent of men are in college in
Thailand so you have a similar shift
even there on what's happening to the
man the documentary we went to a temple
where monks are trying to rehabilitate
young men who fell out of college or
didn't go to college moreover yeah what
they did it's 1618 was turned to alcohol
it was turned to substances yeah to
drive taxis because they could get some
cash because there was no point trying
to compete with the one yeah so you have
these deep societal problems but yet
they are want to be really clear that
the the answer to this is not
um in some way preventing women from
getting an education that's just not
going to function you know how are you
going to do that you know well you
always lose access to half the world's
brain power of course of course and you
know there are people who think then
there are people who I think want to use
this conversation to promote that
because I've seen comments along the
those lines too often this has to be
there for partly about
um men in some way asking why are men
excluded from society why are they
becoming in cells or in Japan they call
them octocus you know the young man who
stays home playing his gaming systems
and mayor see I don't I don't think
that's the right question I think we
almost always ask questions backwards
why people become useless that's not a
mystery
it's easy to be useless the mystery is
why that doesn't happen to everyone all
the time and the answer is because we
build up extremely careful
structures of societal discipline to
encourage people to adopt mature
long-term responsibility and to reward
them judiciously for doing so and when
you allow those structures to collapse
or work consciously to undermine them
then you get default to the default and
the default is useless it's short-term
gratification and so you never need an
explanation for that it's like well why
do people turn to short-term
gratification because it's gratifying in
the short term
it's easy now you know getting men
encouraging men to shed their Peter Pan
persona
juvenile Peter Pan Persona and to adopt
mature responsibility that's a real
challenge for every society and we are
increasingly not only failing at doing
that but punishing young men for
developing
say the virtues of ambition and and uh
well and even sexual desire for that
matter
so
all right so chapter one you went
interviewed a variety of people and and
and and just started to flesh out the
territory how does it unfold after that
well it comes to the point where I
realize there's a moment I realize there
is a connection across all these
countries and it's to do with this
structure of the family you know you
would expect
if you're having fewer children you know
on some of these organizations encourage
people to fewer children have fewer
smaller families you would expect if
they had had an a success or if people
were doing it you would have a lot of
families with only one child
but actually Singletons are actually
really quite rare in life and they're no
more common today than they were 30 40
years ago
so I started to discover you see people
with zero children right that's the only
how do you get a fertility rate of less
than replacement levels either the
number of people having one child are
none
so connecting that allowed me to start
to ask more questions about
childlessness and about aspirations in
life they're not really emotions so it's
not a matter of small families no it's a
matter of no family that's right and
then it's a matter of involuntary known
families right okay got it and that's
why I didn't end up doing any regressive
analysis because it's it's a counting
problem you know we were counting this
the wrong way you just simply need to
look at uh the number of people having
one child two three four and you find
this Gap and you find that getting wider
and wider and they effectively expands
it effectively explains the entire fall
below replacement level but there's
really seriously there's really good
news here too
um the best news in all of this is that
if the majority are significant number
of those people who are involuntarily
unplanned jealousness as I call it if
they were having a family they're not
going to have one they're going to have
in the same proportions one two three
four five plus it's all about having a
first child
so in documentary right well the pre
look the second child is pretty
straightforward after the first and once
you've got two you're already completely
screwed so you might as well have three
well that's then the kids start to take
care of each other by the way too which
is something that parents don't
understand is that yeah you know you
don't if you have eight kids it's not
like you're taking care of eight kids
the kids start to form their own society
and take care of each other yeah current
examples of that in the documentary or
at least on my journey of you saw in
Italy this mother of four children
saying she educated her eldest daughter
taught her how to read she taught the
next story right she told the next one
the next one so that's certainly true
but the good news is here because family
structure is really locked in once of
course
um you know if you go to some countries
as I did in Africa You've Got High birth
rates because of poverty yeah yeah some
more access to reproductive you know
services but mostly that's covered now
mostly it is so we got poverty that
people in Africa need children to go and
get the water but a lot of good things
are being done on that that poverty
level is coming way down and we're
seeing in Africa on average and
sub-Saharan Africa just to cover that
briefly
um the average woman is having one less
child every 15 years it's around four
now so around 30 years time we're
looking at Africa starting to get down
towards replacement level it's on the
same path yeah yeah that's the
reasonable assumption based on the data
right now so once you get to that point
and this is what I think the world of
demography really skipped over
um
is that it's not the same
form it's not like you look at your
families going from four to two and then
down to 1.5 and said this is the same
Trend it's not when you get to
replacement level when women are having
pretty much the family size that they
actually want
childlessness kicks in and it it's that
that pulls it down a different level so
the next part of the documentary then
going to people finding out what their
young people with their aspirations for
the future was then also talking to men
and women who hadn't had children why
they didn't or what it meant to their
lives and that that gets quiet what do
you find on the aspirational front and
oh you know the the majority the
significant majority of people young
people expect or want of children
someday right right now I do have some
concerns but no evidence for it but it's
just a natural concern that what we're
seeing in the world today uh perhaps is
over focus on the environment is through
fear yeah persuading people more than
you would normally expect to not think
of children but have hope around that
because it's this internal desire
it's not so much fear that's interfering
on that front I think it's actually
demoralization
right because
this is especially true for let's say
decent young men who would like to be
moral actors if they're told continually
which they are that all of their male
pattern behaviors for example in school
are disruptive and that their male
ambition is nothing but a reflection of
the tyrannical patriarchy and that any
interest they might evoke
they might events towards women is part
of the predatory pattern of male
Behavior then it demoralizes them
literally it makes them feel like
they're natural proclivity for ambitious
striving let's say and sexual desire is
immoral and the people you hurt the most
by doing that are the people who have a
moral heart because the ones who don't
don't care and the ones who do
I had a friend uh his name was Rob
dernin and uh he was an early he fell
prey to this anti-male narrative very
early in his life this is like 40 years
ago 50 years ago and he was definitely
guilty about
his role as a patriarchal male let's say
and he did everything he could to adopt
a kind of nihilistic Buddhism and just
take himself out of life
you know he thought everything he did
was and everything that men did in
general was just part of the destructive
force that was ravaging the world and he
eventually committed suicide it was
awful I watched that unfold for 50 years
you know and I would say
you know he had his flaws like everyone
does and
in that self-destructive pathway there
can be a fair bit of let's say
unconscious self-serving but
fundamentally he
was overwhelmed by existential guilt in
relationship to being male and that
eventually convinced him to do himself
in
it was quite the
catastrophic Voyage All Things
Considered and I I know perfectly well
that that's not rare because I've talked
to thousands of young men who have been
demoralized to the point of suicide and
that story is
I'd say that's the archetypal story
so it's not fear exactly it's
it's an assault it's a moral assault and
it's on
unconscionable it's an unconscionable
moral assault if you're
a solution to saving the planet is that
you have to demoralize young people so
badly that they even abstain from sex
then there's seriously something wrong
with your world view
and maybe we can call out Paul Ehrlich
on that front for example
so all right so now you're starting to
talk to people about their aspirations
you're finding out young people do want
to have a family and that doesn't mean
one child it means a family and but
they're not prioritizing that properly
or they're they're what happens to the
people who end up without children well
there's no path to it right the path is
education education education usually
not for everyone but and then get
sure that yeah
um but that's not the driver because
education in some countries is much
lower than the U.S so some people will
say oh that's the problem yeah it's not
a good thing it can't help yeah
um and that's career career career right
is guiding people to say actually there
is a moment in time when you really need
to prioritize this so that we've left
young people
to find a path on their own having sent
them off as parents as as as societies
find a path of life that will get them
to where they want to be which everyone
I think implicitly assumes for most
people not all will involve love and
will involve children yeah
but actually what's happening is when
young people are getting to that point
they're often in their 30s because no
one really is is thinking
um that 30 is too late yeah at all yeah
but I mean just another statistic if you
look across every country we had data on
probability of becoming a parent a
mother rather it's on woman again the
probability of someone without children
age 30 ever becoming a parent at most at
most is 50 percent
really that's just the outcome
so by 30 by 30. if you haven't had your
first child by 30 in most countries it's
lower than that
and and why is that is it is do you know
I mean there must be multiple
causes part of that would be
partnerlessness part of that would be
fertility difficulties
um what are the major contributors to
that the major contributor is not
finding a partner yeah at the right time
yeah right or when you do find a partner
it's you have challenges yeah so the
other thing that that is painful to
point out to women is that 30 year old
women aren't competing with other 30
year old women for partners they're
competing with 18 to 35 year old women
for partners and so all things
considered
if you're 30 and you're looking for a
mate and you want children you're
putting an awful lot of pressure one way
or another on your 30 year old male
Target because his option is to find a
25 year old woman
who all things being equal is of the
same value as you are except that you're
30 and that means his time frame is now
shortened in a manner that wouldn't be
the case if he married someone younger
Plus
women tend to prefer men who are
slightly older than them well not
exactly slightly it's actually four
years is the average internationally and
so
the optimal Target for a 25 year old
woman is a 29 year old man and so and
it's it's it's it's it's rude to point
such things out but mate selection is a
very difficult problem and
it's also exacerbated by the fact that
this is also a terrible thing is that
because of this hypergamous tendency of
women as women are I knew a lot of very
successful young women
who worked in the legal field and they
were often stars in their firms
extremely able people and generally they
were very vivacious attractive
intelligent educated
and intimidating as hell to men
and not that interested in someone who
didn't have the same ability and Status
they did which was almost no one so then
there are 30 they're extremely choosy
and you could say they have a right to
be but the problem is well yeah you're
30 and you're extremely choosy and
you're pool of available candidates has
basically shrunk To None because first
of all a lot of men are already snapped
up by the time they're 30. so there's
that reduction right off the bat and
then if you're going to reject eight
women rate 80 percent of men on dating
sites is below average in attractiveness
and that's just the Baseline right for
the women who are high status and high
attraction attractive let's say very
able on the career front and uh they're
the men they're going to regard as
acceptable that's a vanishingly small
proportion of man so that's part of the
reason why they what would you say
select themselves out of the mating
Market that's that's brutal man it's
brutal and I watched women struggle with
that like mad and certainly had no
shortage of sympathy for them but
the mere fact that you're sympathetic to
someone doesn't mean that the brute
reality that confronts them has been
altered in any manner whatsoever
points on that so I agree with all of
that what I see and I I get to
often once or twice a week have a coffee
with a young person who has reached out
and you you know when you talk about the
documentary or friends or friends or
friends someone wants to talk to you
about something personal
a common
um conversation would be
more women more than men
they've been dating someone for five
years yeah
they think they might want to well
different scenarios they think they
might want to settle down and have a
child with them but they've never talked
about it well it's only been five years
right or that they've already figured
out they probably don't want a child
with this person what you can't do
or worst of all they've just broken up
because they've been dating this guy for
seven years and he's not got another
girlfriend who's 25 yeah
and she's pregnant yeah oh my God yeah
that's a brutal situation brutal but
those are real life oh yeah yeah that's
very yeah all that's very common
so the idea of dating someone for an
extended period my children are now you
know you know 27 to 20 you know they're
getting to that point where
you know to me I'm thinking of my own
children what I think of these young
people and the advice I I would give
them and frankly the advice I usually
give and I'm not a clinical psychologist
but um you know people are asking for
advice and I've talked to a lot of
people is if you're unsure
break up because you know what if it
feels wrong after you've broken up
you'll get back together quickly
and I'd say more other advice too is get
the hell out of it you think you have a
long time to decide well here's here's a
way of thinking about it
if you're reasonably attractive
you'll be able to try out five people
that's it
that's what you've got you know because
it takes a while to find someone and
then it takes a while to get to know
them and
finding them and getting to know them
that's probably something approximating
one to two years and if you do that five
times that's ten years and that's your
fertility window and so you think you
have time
but that's a delusion and you think the
right person will come around well first
of all that's a delusion to begin with
because
you build a relationship you don't find
one now you should have some sense when
you pick your partner
to the degree that you have the luxury
to have some sense but the notion that
the person right for you will come along
at the right time that's just that's
just not the case that isn't how things
work at all and if you know that even if
you're very attractive that the list of
true candidates is probably five and
four some people
it's one or zero and so that's
it's hard eh because when you're 17
you're 16 especially if you're
attractive and I would say this is
especially true if you're an attractive
young woman you have no shortage
generally speaking of people who are
interested in you and it looks like that
sort of a landscape of Plenty but that
doesn't mitigate against the fact that
it still takes a long time to get to
know people and to find the right person
now men have it a bit easier on that
front I would say because
like I had one friend who didn't have a
child until he was 55. you know that can
always be the case for men and and so
the pressure isn't on in the same way
but even with men
like how I married my wife earlier we
would have had more kids
you know and that didn't happen
so and we got married comparatively
early for our social class an
educational background
okay so now you're talking to people and
you're finding out they want to have
kids and then they find out that they
don't get to right a little bit too late
and so where does the documentary go
from there so from there we take it into
the consequences
um
well they're partly personal
um but partly economic but everything
ultimately is personal because
everything ultimately comes back to you
know whether it's you and your life and
how you live and whether you're lonely
or not yeah or how much the state can
help you particularly in your later
years through Healthcare through
pensions through your city providing
basic services like water it all comes
back together so we explore a lot of
those and by the way I I sat down with I
believe about a dozen experts many
professors many you know
a priest a monk uh people are involved
working with government Healthcare
programs around the world so we hear
these voices and other than uh one
organization which happens to be the
successor to what polar like set up
um they were the only organization who
took an optimistic view of course she
would they would do that everybody else
is negative everybody else is worried
about the future consequences of this
um and just by the way I I should call
this out Ehrlich set up an organization
uh author of the population bomb of
course called zpg which evolved into
your population growth yeah it evolved
into another organization that still has
something like 30
000 teachers who train other teachers
who educate 4 million U.S high school
kids every year
and they explain the population problems
usually in Africa and their message is
please think about this yeah well
there's nothing there's nothing racist
about the Too Many African narrative
yeah when you teach someone like
two and two is four you don't say think
about that but when you say here's the
problem in Africa and you say to a think
about that you're not really saying
think about Africa you're thinking about
you know do you want the kids or not sir
that's covered in the documentary as
well as part of the narrative as to why
we still have this Viewpoint when
frankly we should have known about this
you know decades ago yeah we can also
look at the
self-evident economic statistics
demonstrating that since Paul Ehrlich
and his population bomb in the club of
Rome Etc these anti-population zealots
started beating the drum back in 1965.
saying that we were all going to starve
to death by the year 2000 when we'll
have four billion people God help us and
now have eight and the relationship
between wealth growth and population has
been extremely positive not negative or
flat and everyone on the planet
virtually is richer than well that
anyone had ever conceived of and it's
clearly the case that we could manage
this if we had half the will to do it
so the data are in
one of the things I've really learned is
that
I believe the whole idea of natural
resource almost the whole idea of
natural resource is specious
in that
human beings the wealth of the planet
is dependent on
the psychological health and the
structures of governance that are put in
place by people of Good Will and that if
we organize ourselves properly and aim
up there's no real limit to abundance
and it's certainly not population
dependent we're not in a zero-sum game
we are not yeast in a petri dish we're
not doomed to a malthusian outcome and
the biologists who make that claim and
say it's scientific are assuming that
the yeast in the petri dish model of
human function is the appropriate
biological model
and it's not and the reason for that is
because we can let our ideas die instead
of us and we can learn and we can
transform and we're very good at that
and
there's no
justification whatsoever
for stating that it's a scientific fact
that population increase is going to
produce a malthusian catastrophe now it
can in limited circumstances but we are
not East in a Petri dish that's the
wrong model
so and I can't disagree I mean I'm a
data analyst I I'm only prepared to
comment when I've done my own work or
I've seen detailed work of others I
can't imagine how complicated
it must be to model the planet I mean
that's on a level beyond anything any
you know rational statistician could do
alone it's models on top of models on
top of models yeah so where I Tower of
Babel so where I come from is look to be
honest with you I don't know but I do
know that we are adaptive I do know that
we should prepare because to be honest
with you you know green technologies
sound like pretty cool things when you
look at Teslas out there they're not
perfect but they're
remembering I work with a lot of the
bottom of clients but what Elon has done
for the industry you know is phenomenal
and if we come at this from a point of
view of positivity what can we do and I
look at my own kids and well their
generation the malays the the belief
that the world is coming to an end the
world is not coming to an end
in that direction which we seem to be
striving to do with all diligence at the
moment well then to bring it back to the
the documentary at this point we we come
back to this point of loneliness and
meet people and and I mean there's a
scene where I go to a crematorium in
Germany
and I'm hoping to find out something
about what it's like to
bury people who have no family I nearly
got an interview uh directly with the
director but he refused to meet me on an
intermediary kind of sat down to explain
why
and it's horrendous and so this is off
camera
um but I got a a long note recently with
more information as to what's happening
people with no family and Care Homes are
being effectively mistreated
malnourished yes tied to their beds for
long periods of time and
we know this so it's known in this
crematorium because
the bodies that come are I guess right
marked yeah
and they weren't prepared to say because
they're fearful of the system so you
know that's someone should make a
documentary about that alone but it
tells you that the life of these people
without family
you know and we can't see it because
these people whether it be in that
suburb in Japan or in Germany or
anywhere else these people are spending
their lives in their homes alone hidden
from from the world so well the thing is
in our culture we only seem to be able
to apprehend
life until about 30. like that's our
vision you know the vision is you're
young you're full of promise you get
educated you have your career and then
you're 30. and what's happening well now
you're successful it's like okay but you
got 60 years left there what are you
gonna do with that
well how long is your career going to
run you well you know lots of people
think about early retirement and that's
particularly perhaps the case if you're
successful economically so let's say you
retire at 50. okay
fair enough
you got 45 years left what's your vision
for that
well now you're alone you don't have a
family you don't have a partner you
don't have a career either
so um what are you planning to do
exactly what's your vision and the
answer is we don't have a vision for
that we don't have a vision for the
expanse of our life
and so and that's an interesting thing
in and of itself I mean
you know for a long time
back in the 1860s
people even in the west were struggling
along on less than a dollar fifty a day
in today's money and it's not like
people had the luxury of developing a
lifetime Vision they were sort of
fending off one disaster disaster after
another like people do now who live in
absolute privation there's about 800
million people like that still on the
planet
and then once you get a little wealthier
a little more secure you can start
thinking about the future and
but that's very very complicated and
this luxurious wealth we have is new
enough so that our capacity to develop a
lifetime Vision hasn't developed
to a degree that's sophisticated enough
to take that whole time span into
account but this vision of
isolated death with no one around you
that cares that's I wouldn't recommend
that as
your life from 70 to 95.
it's pretty damn dismal so
Jordan it's going to be worse in less
industrialized nations because you go to
Brazil and as professors there I met
three of them the freeze they used was
we're getting old before we got rich in
Brazil right so they can't provide the
infrastructure resources to the elderly
on a level comparable to what we can so
the life of elderly people so I look at
when I look at India with the birth rate
now below replacement level growing
population because it's so young people
are living longer which is a good thing
but I'm looking at a future for India 30
years from now where you're going to
have so many old people and so few
people to take care of them
so this is a problem that we focus too
much on in our own societies this is a
global humanitarian crisis of old people
who are going to be left by and large to
some extent offend for themselves and
when they're not fending for themselves
you know it they're going to be mostly
in their homes or alone and you know I
find that I find the psychological
argument I would say probably more
compelling I I think not because I take
any issue to your forward-looking
projections but because
things are so unstable on the
technological and economic and political
front that projecting even a decade into
the future seems in some ways like a
Fool's errand right because
God only knows what's coming down the
pipelines with regards to
new technology but I think you can make
an extraordinary strong case that one of
the things you don't want to end up
happening to you in your own life is to
be
involuntarily childless and isolated
starting at the age of 30 going forward
right and so I do you know I I've I've
looked at the situation in China and in
Japan
with this what do they call that the
inverted pyramidal distribution where
there's way more old people than young
people and obviously that seems
untenable on the technological or on the
economic front but um I do think the the
psychological issue is
much more
present should be much more present for
young people and the warning is don't be
thinking you've got a lot of time to get
your act together because you don't have
as much time as you think and you want
to get things going
sooner than you
might find it convenient there's never a
convenient time to have a child there's
stupid times to have a child for sure
but there's never a convenient time and
that's the other thing people do too you
know
um when my wife and I finally got
together she was about 28 or so she
wanted to have a kid pretty
you know pretty much right away and uh
I was finishing off my postdoc and I
hadn't got a permanent job yet and my
sense was well you know everything's not
in place and we talked that out for
quite a while and decided to proceed
regardless because
there was no real reason for me to be
concerned the probability that I was
going to be jobless was barring
catastrophe zero and you jump into the
abyss holding hands with your wife you
know it there's no right time
and the reason that's so important to
know is because the clock ticks while
you're waiting and that's also a
catastrophe and then it sneaks up on
people unawares as you just described
and takes them out not good okay so now
you're talking now you're investigating
in the documentary the consequences of
this involuntary childlessness and do
you progress past that yeah well so the
consequences go into both
Detroit we look at what might happen to
the future of the world based on what's
happened to Detroit yeah yeah we look at
briefly
um future pension systems we look at
AI technology but only very briefly it's
an area that I'm sure many people like
you mentioned technology just now but
you know a comment for me is that robots
don't pay taxes so simply saying there's
something else you don't necessarily
want to take care of you
so we'll just see how that works out and
I think they're going to be expensive so
the idea that AI is a solution just like
this yeah yeah is
probably oversimplified possibly very
oversimplified but of course it has a
role technology definitely has a role in
this but we can't just turn away from
this subject and say let's not worry
about it for that reason
the final part of the documentary and I
have to credit a friend I thought it was
done after filming in probably 18
countries I thought well this is enough
now kind of I can see the global pattern
and uh this friend in La said no you
haven't finished you have to go to
Africa and you have to go to other
countries like Bangladesh
and India had already been to but I
wanted to more filming I wanted to go
into we went to slums in Mumbai we went
to slums in uh Rio uh I think five in
Johannesburg
um and I wanted to see what's happening
in the parts of the world that I think
to some extent we might fear are
exploding
and you have
the same fundamental story happening
everywhere even Nigeria
um so Nigeria is a good example of a
country that's moving towards lower
birth rates at a much slower Pace
there'll be more people by the way in
Nigeria by the year 2100 than there are
in China for everyone watching and
listen that's quite the shocking bit of
information yeah and you know you look
at Nigeria you still have a culture
there where the more male children you
have it's part of a what you might say
that the bravado that yeah yeah it's
like that's that status reward status
yeah but you go to Ethiopia and you meet
people there and you talk professors
there and Ethiopia used to be like that
but the birth rate right now in Ethiopia
is four it needs to be seven or eight
not that long ago and there's a
transformation happening so you can see
and feel the transformation happening in
Africa just like everywhere else so I
like to think of the analogy that the
world is on a roller coaster
and countries like Japan and Germany and
Italy and now South Korea are in the
front car you know they're over in terms
of the peak population and sure they're
aging and people are going to live
longer and longer so we're not going to
really see the the drop for a little
while but we know what's coming
Africa is in the rare car you know
they're still on the way up but the path
is the same here yeah but perhaps the
thing that struck me about
Africa where I'm planning to go back and
spend a significant amount of time for
my own purposes as much as anything when
you go to Africa you go to Malawi which
is I believe World Bank did the 12th
poorest country in the world by GDP per
person
and you go to community and people are
laughing smiling and you go to kind of a
an area it's not even a soccer pitch
it's nothing like a soccer pitch but
there's a soccer ball there yeah there's
no rules but you got 30 kids running and
screaming and laughing yeah and we're
there you know and you know they come
and say hi for a moment but they want to
get back and play soccer with each other
and to see that sense of community and
that intergenerational Community you
know maybe in some ways part of a
solution here that we've you know I
think an argument for me is that we've
lost a sense of community for one reason
or another
and uh so you know that that's you know
something that surprised me actually how
similar really we all are and we're just
of different parts of this of that cycle
right
um so so you've you've laid out this
documentary and you've documented a
problem that is not being attended to
much
that's a very pervasive problem and
that's going to affect
virtually everyone personally and
sociologically
we talked a little bit about pathways
you know I mean it's one thing obviously
to diagnose a problem and that's not a
straightforward thing to do to see the
problem and then to diagnose it it's a
completely different order of things to
start thinking about what might
constitute an acceptable alternative so
in Hungary what they've done you
probably know this is that
if you're a mother in Hungary you have
one child
you're now exempt from income tax at the
federal level for the rest of your life
it's 25 and then that scales up to 100
percent for four children and the idea
there was both practical and cultural so
the cultural idea was
we need to signal that we value
motherhood and children and one of the
more powerful signals that that
Society has acts to is access to his
economic signals and the hungarians have
stopped the decline in their birth rate
and tapped it up slightly they've
increased female participation in the
workforce by the way 13 percent
so the feminists had objected or some of
them that
the Hungarian government was just
turning women into baby making factories
which is hell of a you know nasty
epithet I might add but um what's
happened is the reverse is more women
are working now than before and I
suppose that's because they get to keep
more of their money you know and uh they
can make Child Care Arrangements more
straightforwardly and all of that
they've knocked a divorce rate down
substantively they've increased the
marriage rate they've knocked the
abortion rate down 40 38 with no
compulsion right it's not as easy to get
an abortion and Hungary as it is in the
U.S or Canada and the legal limits there
is 12 weeks instead of the 16 weeks
which is about what Americans think it
should be but the point is these
alterations in policy have
produced
increases in
fertility increases in the marital rate
decreases in the divorce rate decreases
in the abortion rate and those look
arguably like desirable things do you
see and we talked a little bit about the
fact that women live seven years longer
and so in principle have a time let's
say eight years where they could have
children without really being at a
competitive disadvantage on the economic
front with men assuming that it is a
competitive landscape and that's also
not particularly obvious to me I mean
what have you have have your thoughts
turned to what might constitute an
appropriate pathway forward for young
people well I certainly
um would uh
quite boldly say what will not work
because there's so many examples of
things have been tried and tried and
tried and tried now we'll come back to
Hungary in a moment yes it is very
interesting
um but if you look at baby bonus
programs yeah globally I
that's what they do is temporarily
increases the birth rate
and then you see a dip and the dip
usually goes below where it was before
all you've done is bring forward the the
people who would have had kids anyway
yeah yeah right right right
so we and you look at the amount of
money in certain Japan certainly South
Korea are spending on kindergarten yeah
yeah that doesn't seem to help Quebec it
didn't make a bit of difference yeah
yeah no it isn't it isn't lack of child
care that's causing this problem yeah
and it's not income either no right A
lot of people think it is incumbent it's
a natural thing I think for people
thinking well if I had a little bit more
money or you know at the right time you
know or my apartment's too small but
actually what what you find is that when
people have more money in their pocket
birth rates go down yeah right they do
other things yeah it's like not yet not
you know we can take this vacation well
I think also well I also think that
their expert expectations for what
constitutes sufficiently prepared for
children also change
you know like I said when I was in
Montreal well you know I was already
educated I had a job it was clear I was
going to get a job but my standard for
what was sufficient security and
opportunity for my children Rose along
with my Horizon of Vision on the
economic front and it's also not the
case that more security makes you
likable to take more risks that isn't
how life works you have to jump into
children just like you jump into a
marriage or into into your life for that
matter I think that's the key point you
know so ultimately Uh Hungry aside for a
moment I'm also Russia in the past has
had similar programs where they have put
significant benefits in places that seem
to have worked for a time
um but vast majority of financial
incentives or even societal
changes such as kindergartens yeah have
very limited effects very limited indeed
if we come back to understand the
fundamentals of the problem is this
unplanned childlessness issue
perhaps what Hungary might have got
right
and you know I you know
I will never frankly tell someone you
sure should not have an abortion that's
your choice that's not something I want
to have any so I don't believe it's my
right to say that that's just my
personal position on it but what
hungering might have done it and you you
still a moment ago just make it more
positive the idea of parenting yeah
that's what they're aiming at yeah the
hungarians do understand so they're
president cattle and Novak uh young
Dynamic woman who who is their symbolic
head of state was very much involved in
the formulation of these family policies
and she knew perfectly well that part of
what the goal was was to
culturally Elevate the let's call it the
sacred significance of motherhood
something like that to to put the mother
again
on something on something approximating
the necessary pedestal you know you see
this in Catholic imagery all the time is
that of course in the Christian
tradition Christ is obviously the
central figure of redemption and
Divinity but there's strong competition
symbolically on the part of Mary because
it's Mary and the infant and I would say
any society that doesn't hold the mother
and infant as sacred is doomed
for obvious reasons since we all had
mothers and we're all infants if you
don't value that whatever that value
means and when my wife had little kids
she was treated pretty damn dismally I
would say you know I used to go out to
restaurants with her and just watch when
she entered in with the kids and there
was a lot of sneers and a lot of you
know Miss casual mistreatment there was
no they were a nuisance you know and
that was extremely annoying to me to
watch because I don't think of kids as
kids can be nuisances if they're not
well behaved but you there's something
wrong with you if you think children are
fundamentally a nuisance and and it's
definitely the case that
we don't value
the contribution of young mothers in our
culture the way that we would if we were
wise and that's a very difficult problem
to solve right all this emphasis on you
know the kind of hedonic Freedom that's
associated with you with being a
youthful teenager and then that equally
Sex in the City nonsense about you know
the your your freedom on the sexual
front while you're pursuing your career
it's a bloody juvenile that it's almost
incomprehensible but it's not an easy
thing to reverse and it isn't even
obvious that it's the government's rule
to re reverse that but and the outcomes
are unplanned childlessness right time
and time again I think you know it's
just clear that people who could on that
path are thinking of what Society tells
them they can do in the short term only
and that'd be a good title for this this
uh this interview really we should
probably call it unplanned childlessness
I love that well because that's that is
so it's so interesting that that exists
as such a plague and yet it isn't
identified and it doesn't have a name
and that's a real that's a real
catastrophe I
um you know one of the earliest
greetings I did there was a young man it
was in Japan but he was he's from the US
and he just stood there afterwards
gazing the ceiling and he's probably 30
early 30 35. and he said unplanned
childlessness and he looked at me and
said that that's me huh yeah that's me
and you could see it it wasn't just the
term it was talking yeah right he was
talking the realization realization you
actually have to in some way have a plan
even if the plan is to do something not
a rational but to take a leap of faith
of faith and to come back to man as well
in this men can't have children aged 55.
um you know I divorced sadly
um you know at around 40 I guess and I
thought there'd be a time where I would
meet someone again and have more
children that's something I would have
desired frankly
um not to get too personal but I it
wasn't my plan for life to be a divorced
dad right right and uh what what you
find is
um that you're competing with younger
men yeah right for the same younger you
said that done Easier Said Yes the fact
that you can technically have a child in
almost any age as a man doesn't mean
that you're going to so the outcome is I
don't know what makes you think you're
going to be more successful old and
ugly than you had been young and ugly
right so yeah yeah and every year you're
on the path to get older I'm uglier
um so so you know it it's man and woman
in this situation I think that Society
needs to make parenting
something more valuable but to come back
to your point that cannot be the
sacrifice of Career Education options we
have to make it more
almost the default option
that you can continue your education I
love the idea of lifelong learning which
is what I'm doing yeah yeah well it's
very odd that we Orient our our
educational establishments to people
between 18 and 22. I just can't figure
that at all I taught at the Harvard
Extension school by the way I had a lot
of adult students and I enjoyed teaching
them a lot there's absolutely no reason
whatsoever that the university should
specialize in 18 to 22 year olds I do
that's a that's a hangover from
well I don't know God I don't even know
when that was useful and relevant it's
just not a smart idea and it's in the
college's interest because that's a
shrinking number of children come
through these systems universities are
going to need to diverse yeah lifelong
learning is the answer to that so why
but it's also the case that in an era of
Rapid technological transformation that
lifelong learning is necessary
practically but it's also why the hell
wouldn't you want that because it's part
of what keeps you updated so I remember
the first class I took at the extension
school it was in statistics that I went
to my first class probably dressed like
I am now at the leather briefcase and uh
everyone else I was not the oldest at
all yeah but everyone else is in jeans
and t-shirts and you know backpacks and
yeah
I haven't dressed like that for for
decades but I went out and you know I
got a couple of t-shirts and a backpack
and you know the most uh
transformational thing happened to me
first recognition I'm learning something
I want to learn yeah right I'm fully
engaged and that makes you the best kind
of student too I think so but everyone
else
there were Harvard College kids there
taking somebody yeah and there were
people older than me it didn't matter
yeah yeah I love teaching at the
extension school I mean at Harvard the
undergraduates in the formal School were
smarter than the people on average in
the extension school but the extension
school people were a lot more motivated
to learn right there there was no one
not attending right because they were
there because they wanted to be there
right so I'm probably asking questions
that were I actually took a psychology
class uh
um probably in the building William
James yeah William James yeah yeah and
uh you know you know again I was there
with a lot of even high school learners
at a summer school program but I
realized the professor was enjoying the
questions I was asking yeah they're just
different to the question yeah yeah
they're serious questions right yeah so
when were you there uh that I started in
2015 2016 I would have taken the
psychology probably 101 of course but
you know the point is that the
recruitment cycle
for many career options is linked to the
education cycle so you can't change one
without the other yeah yeah you have
enough people say well it's fine certain
companies a lot of recruitment later in
life but it's not the normal thing to do
it's a risk so if you're a woman or a
parent taking time out to raise a family
because you think you want to do that
exclusively earlier on that's a risk
today you might not get on that path and
you might not get the recruit yeah you
know I don't really buy that I don't
really buy that because I had one
student for example Shelly Taylor
who uh no sorry Shelly Carson
um she came back to Harvard as a
graduate student out in her 40s I was
younger than her as her supervisor she'd
been an airline stewardess pretty middle
class life had been out of the academic
extreme for quite a while and was quite
a lot older than most of the graduate
students and she
hit it hard and developed a bang-up
career and she's managed that quite
successfully and I think that that's not
normal you know it's not the standard
practice but it's by no means impossible
and given that women do have that seven
year advantage in terms of lifespan
there's man
you think you're out of the running on
the education and career front when
you're 35 you're out of the running on
the reproductive front yeah you're not
really out of the running on the
education and career front and I've seen
lots of people
hit the education ground running in
their 30s mid-30s sometimes later and
have a whole new career I mean Jesus at
40. you can still have 30 years at your
new career so that's that's a very
optimistic way of looking at it and yeah
and so all right so well for everybody
watching and listening on YouTube and
its Associated platforms thank you very
much for your time and attention
and uh
to Stephen Shaw for agreeing to talk to
me today about birth Gap and about the
issue of uh declining birth rates and
and population shrinkage
um bringing that to everyone's attention
bringing the issue of unplanned
childlessness to everyone's attention
because that's a crucial issue here to
note the existence of a problem and to
give it a name is to bring it out of the
darkness and to unshroud it let's say
and that's an extremely useful thing to
do and I'm going to talk to Stephen for
another half an hour on the daily wire
plus platform I'd like to spend half an
hour with my guests
investigating how their
pathway through life made it manifest
made itself manifest to them both in
terms of the problems that grip them
the concerns they had both voluntary and
involuntary and the opportunities that
presented themselves as a consequence
and so if you're interested in that then
please head over to the Daily Word plus
platform you could consider supporting
them in any case they have also worked
diligently to make the kind of
conversations I had today uh possible
and that's much appreciated to the film
crew here in Vancouver because that's
where I am today thank you very much and
uh
thank you all for your time and
attention
good to talk with you yeah yep you bet
you bet
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guests on dailywireplus.com